[Música]
deseaba tanto hacer este viaje porque
cuando dios la vida el universo quieren
que uno haga algo le inyecta una idea a
través de una señal mi primera señal fue
en el aeropuerto de bogotá un hombre
vestido de blanco con un sombrero muy
extraño se volteó y me dijo las pero me
estás
y donde su casa en la sierra nevada de
santa marta
en ese instante poco sabía de su cultura
su tradición sus formas de vida pero
pasaron diez años hasta que por una
coincidencia de la vida estaba montada
en un avión rumbo a valledupar a vivir
el viaje de buscar mi corazón porque
durante muchísimo tiempo había aprendido
cosas espirituales talleres sentía que
tenía mucho conocimiento pero me faltaba
ese encuentro con mi alma y con mi
corazón pero bueno como vieron la
caminata no es nada fácil llegamos y
dice el guía que nos lleva que haber
subido toda la montaña no nos
garantizaba poder entrar al lugar que
iba a salir una persona y nos iba a
mirar como el alma o la energía y nos
iba a decir si podíamos pasar en ese
instante se me vino toda la vida que
traía a cuestas
todas las historias las cosas tan
bonitas o no tan bonitas que había hecho
conmigo con mi propio ser con la
humanidad y dije mí
espero que pueda entrar
están todos estos niños que vieron en el
vídeo allí y yo mejor emoción al tipo
que belleza emoción quien viene
caminando el señor que filtra la entrada
y se me cae una araña y empiezo a gritar
como lo que yo
una araña gigante
donde éstos sólo se burlaban y pienso
que yo diría la mujer más extraña como
se asusta con una araña y llega el señor
coge la araña
y ésta vuelve y meshal
y empieza a recorrer método del brazo
por detrás y esta vez tuve pánico pero
en silencio
deje de gritar
porque no sé
bien existe lo único que me dijo fue
aprende de la araña mi único
conocimiento era que la araña puestos
tenía diez elefantes a mi me encantaron
esa canción un elefante se balanceaba
y como vieron que resistía
y así va contando y contando hasta
adicto
entonces me bajé y dije ok que tengo que
aprender de la araña y resulta que uno
de los hechos más asombrosos de la
naturaleza es que la araña tiene aquí en
su vientre una seda líquida que expulsa
y al entrar en contacto con el viento se
hace el patrón este patrón que ustedes
ven aquí
y la araña es ciega
ya que si la araña ciega y todo su oro
líquido está aquí y ella va tejiendo
cada vez más fuerte con el tacto puse a
pensar los seres humanos tenemos la
fuerza de voluntad la creación de
nuestra vida aquí aquí se conecta el
cordón umbilical con nuestra madre aquí
está la capacidad de tener las emociones
fuertes que nos ayudan a soportar el
peso de la vida pero nosotros tenemos
una dualidad a veces esas emociones para
entrar en contacto con el viento salen
por donde por nuestra voz y a veces
sacamos más palabras de las que
quisiéramos decir a veces no le ponemos
filtro entonces si por un momento
imaginan su historia con los años que
tienen hasta hoy todas las palabras que
han dicho cómo sería el tejido y
estarían suspendidos por esas palabras
imaginen piensen por un segundo
sería fuerte
sería resistente o tendría huecos de las
relaciones que hemos quebrado al
reaccionar
este tejido es muy importante que lo
empecemos a construir hoy porque la
invitación que me estaban haciendo era
recuperar la inocente la inocencia
porque a través de la palabra yo tenía
que filtrar la con mi corazón cada vez
que a una emoción le ponemos corazón
actuamos mejor pensamos mejor decidimos
mejor y hace tacto se vuelve fuerte y el
tejido se vuelve hermoso porque la
invitación al volver a la inocencia era
muy sencilla a nosotros en nuestra
comunidad en nuestra tierra y donde
vivimos nos enseñan a tenerle miedo a
una araña pero no un arma nos enseñan a
tenerle miedo a la conexión con la
tierra untar nos de barro a estar sucio
pero si nos dicen que mejor guardes
todas tus pertenencias bajo llave nos
enseñan también que nosotros tenemos
algo que perder cuando tú vas a la
sierra te das cuenta que tienes todo que
ganar así que no solo buscando una
fórmula para conectarme como la araña
podría sostener diez elefantes y cómo
este es el elefante se balanceaba me di
cuenta que los elefantes representaban
los más grandes sueños y que esos sueños
eran lo que ustedes quieran poner y
tienen el peso que ustedes quieran esos
sueños son su fortaleza su capacidad y
toda la capacidad de pensar y hoy los
invito a activar tres cosas importantes
porque se está acabando el año porque
tenemos la capacidad de volver a
reinventar primero la inocencia
recuperen la capacidad de asombro
segundo las emociones fuertes cuáles son
esas emociones fuertes pues la fuerza de
voluntad el amor la armonía la capacidad
de retener el impulso de atacar
la capacidad de actuar sin pensar esas
son emociones fuertes que tenemos que
recuperar y por último pongan de corazón
a todo si ustedes en este instante
tienen sueños pendientes asuntos
pendientes en su vida por resolver cosas
que quisieran tejer hacia un futuro y no
lo ve y lo encuentran como
adquieran la certeza de que allí a
través de esos estilos invisibles a
través de su capacidad de ponerle
corazón a la emoción pensamiento corazón
y palabra esos sueños van a venir a
usted y cómo van a llegar pues qué más
da la araña ciega a veces nosotros
también somos ciegos ante la vida y ante
las maravillas de que hoy simplemente
les quiero decir gracias por recuperar
la inocencia
[Aplausos]